really great to see you he joins us now
from
loughborough uh so what a week it was
for you have you come down from cloud
noun yet
uh no i don't think i have yet thank you
very much for having me uh first of all
yeah it's been an incredible honor
to uh to be able to represent team gb
and
to come away with two medals and uh i
guess be
recording olympic champion is is
something i could have never
dreamed of so yeah it's pretty yeah
pretty amazing
and also racing in in the mixed relay
team which was was a new thing for
the olympics do you think this is going
to become a real fixture now because it
seems to have been pretty popular
yeah certainly for us we we just wanted
to
to race and make make the mixed relay
look like a really viable event for the
olympics
um especially with it being the first
time it had happened and
for us to to have four perfect legs and
across that finish line first was really
quite special and
yeah i was incredibly proud to be part
of uh team gb
uh for that for that moment yeah what
was what was that finish like for you
um because you you're up against vincent
louis who who i understand
the french champion who who you of
course
have got a relationship with with anyway
in terms of friendship and support
what what was that last leg like for you
yeah vince has a been an incredible
mentor for me
he's a a two-time world champion and
current reigning world champion so it's
definitely nerve-wracking going on to
that last leg with him
just a little bit behind me jason and
he attacked me on that the last lap of
the bike and it definitely made
made things tough for me and i just
played to my strengths as best i could
and i was yeah incredibly lucky to
to for things to go right in my way and
and yeah to come away with the win
but yeah he's been an incredible mentor
for me and it was great to kind of share
that moment with him and the podium
but yeah i understand that he sent you
um you know equipment and clothing early
on in your career
um you know what was he saying to you at
the end there
did you want it back
you know he was he was just thrilled i
think he
i think he's just really proud to play a
part in in
yeah the the kind of success that
that we were lucky to have there and he
was an incredible mentor and and the
fact that he believed in me
back in 2012 was was really really
special and
i think it just it speaks for more than
just uh our relationship i think
it goes for the whole of triathlon that
there's incredible relationships between
all athletes and
that they all want to uh
yeah lift each other and and get the
best out of everyone i think
at the end of the day that's everyone's
goal at the olympics is just
performed to the best of their ability
on that one day at the biggest stage of
all
and jamie brownlee of course a real
inspiration to you as well what was it
like to compete with him
yeah i mean johnny and alistair were the
two people who
really inspired me the most especially
in 2012 uh the olympic games i remember
going to watch and not even being able
to get to the the front row to
to be right on the sidelines uh because
there was that many people and
that they really lit a fire for me and
their success uh really inspired me and
to be able to share that moment with
johnny uh where he
finally completed his olympic medal set
was was really quite special and
um yeah i hope i can keep their legacy
going and
and yeah grow the sport the way they
have already
well what about that legacy you've got
every confidence we're going to be
seeing you in paris next
well time who knows what can happen over
three years for me that the main thing
is that i
i'm probably i'm not going to change how
i approach sport how
how things how i train day in day out
for me
i just i just love what i do and i don't
want
things to change in that sense and i
guess it's brought me that success and
why can't it bring more success and what
yeah
for me the main thing is i just want to
inspire as many athletes who are
already doing triathlon who or who
maybe you want to give it a go and and
and that's the main thing i want to
yeah do with the success is just tell
people why not why can't this be you
because i'm just like anyone else i'm
just a normal person who
works hard and just enjoys what i do and
do you think that
the triathlon has really had something
of a makeover in recent years
you know i remember looking back
generations that it it
it was never really seen as something
that anyone could do it was it was a bit
like the iron man it was a
it was something for the very fit but
but now so many people have embraced it
and so many people
are attempting triathlons themselves um
you know
are you seeing a real resurgence in the
number of people coming into it
yeah certainly i think triathlon is a
challenge i think
it's it's extremely tough event but it's
extremely achievable as well if you
if you work hard and you enjoy it and
that goes for
not just young people but uh people of
all ages and
i think it's incredible to see the
amount of well the resurgence that
alistair and johnny have brought into
the sport and
um triathlon has ex
a whole range of distances that you can
you can race from the
super sprint races which only would take
between half an hour and 45 minutes all
the way to the iron man which can take
up to 16 hours so it's it's got
an event for everyone